fighting continues unabated in eastern
Ukraine at least three people reportedly
died wednesday in the rebel stronghold
of donetsk when a hospital was shelled
officials say several more were killed
overnight the escalation has prompted
France and Germany to launch a new
diplomatic offensive for peace on
Thursday evening ukrainian President
Petro poroshenko welcomed French
president Francois Hollande and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel to Kiev he
thanked them for their diplomatic
efforts I really appreciate that you
accept my invitation and make a decision
to economy virgin time US Secretary of
State John Kerry is also in Kiev he told
Ukraine's Prime Minister Arseniy
Yatsenyuk that Washington was
considering how to provide further
support among those options obviously is
the possibility of providing defensive
defensive assistance the president will
make his decision I'm confident soon but
not before he's had a chance to hear
back from myself earlier Thursday Kerry
also met with President poroshenko Kerry
pledged millions in fresh humanitarian
aid he said Russian aggression was the
biggest threat and said Moscow must stop
supporting the separatists